here's a thought experiment could
artificial intelligence governor's
populism and disinformation are on the
rise and politics across the world seems
to be dominated by emotions and
strongman personalities leaders often
seem to be more interested in short-term
political gains than the long-term needs
of their electorate but could machines
do a better job imagine a world where
decisions are made based on impartial
facts and data where the decision makers
are unconcerned by scandals immune to
corruption and have no vested interest
in maintaining their popularity a world
where climate change is a more pressing
issue than the results of the latest
focus group and where global leaders
don't risk instigating world war 3 by
ranting on twitter at 2:00 a.m. sound
too good to be true in fact scientists
believe there are no plausible
circumstances in which machines would or
could replace governments entirely while
a machine might be able to make
incredibly complex calculations it would
have no objective concept of right and
wrong no definitive way of deciding
what's best for example it might be able
to objectively analyze the financial
cost of keeping someone alive through
medical treatment
but it cannot quantify whether the human
life is worth that cost and while you
could argue our current politicians may
not be subject to enough accountability
it would be impossible to hold a machine
accountable for its mistakes after all
what you do in a machine misbehaves tell
its motherboard it's not quite the
terminator but perhaps the biggest risk
in the medium term is the use of lethal
automatic weapons while there is
currently human oversight if drones were
ever authorized to make life-or-death
decisions one mistake could trigger an
automatic reaction and cause an
accidental flash war which frankly
sounds a tad more terrifying than Arnie
stealing your clothes boots and
motorcycle as hard as it might be to
believe technology which surpasses human
intelligence is decades if not centuries
away but even if it existed scientists
argue that it would be no more useful in
government than the world's most
intelligent human instead it is far more
likely that the use of artificial
intelligence in government will continue
on its current trajectory as an aide in
decision-making with humans having
ultimate power AI is already being used
to assist in deciding who gets grants or
benefits in health care and policing but
think of it like var with a human being
acting as the referee of course says
machines are programmed by humans and
their conclusions used to support human
decisions they can be susceptible to
human bias and their findings can be
used selectively machines learn from
data which is gathered from the world we
live in as opposed to the world we'd
like to live in
in places like the u.s. where
african-americans are often
disproportionately and in some cases
lethally targeted by the police
predictive policing could interpret
existing data to potentially perpetuate
those discriminatory patterns sadly it
would seem that machine learning is no
more equipped than human beings to make
big ethical calls AI would not be an
infallible replacement for flawed human
beings how we use AI to government
whether or not it is manipulated or how
mistakes are made are all down to human
beings themselves in short AI is much
more human than he ever realized which
is perhaps the scariest notion
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon